last time I sat down with yous no baby  now baby and you look the same  how have you done this compression  garments and a lot of support and half  way might be a new mama but she's not  letting that slow her down how are you  how's the baby how's Adam every family's  thank goodness doing very very well the  actress is busy traveling the globe  promoting Alice Through the Looking  Glass House is counting on you must be  hard to leave him at home I can barely  leave my cat at home but not to worry  her husband's holding down the fort an  item has he been good with sharing  diaper duties and everything he does as  as is was to be expected he's  spectacular